oh there Mike welcome back to another
chapter of dirty RT this is chapter 12
my name is Rob joined here with Jake
Jake we caught wind of an abundance of
crime in sanh Denis do DoD won't stand
for that he won't and will not if only
if there's only one person like he's the
only one who can commit crime you know
right he's allowed to but no one else is
no one else is allowed to commit crimes
in this game in this world so we need to
go to San Denis and become a vigilante
we need to take care of this crime this
this influx of just [ __ ] and blood
faces them we got to silence them so one
of the ways we're gonna go about this
when we get to Santa knee is you know I
think I think we all can agree that
vigilantes peru's on the rooftops so and
at night maybe we'll make camp outside
and then the enter at night yeah that
sounds about right so we'll wait for the
the mask of the evening to go about and
it's also when crime really surfaces is
that night so that's the best way in
fact sound effect yeah I would get off
to it's got a hatchet in this is this
you're already mobile huh well it is now
Mike and can come along Mike Mike gives
your sidekick come on Mac come on mark I
think we found our first crime
[Laughter]
it's okay it's the origin story you're
trying to throw it through the window
there you go this is the origin story
how I become well that was a traumatic
experience yeah it was pretty traumatic
oh I lost the Artie 'mobile Shh it's
okay we'll find another one we got to
come up with a superhero name too he
needs to have like a like a you know a
fear of something
what is our Artie fear uh well it's
certainly not dirt it's certainly Oh he
who is not ready for that
that's how I fall over now I just like
slightly turn and hit a face okay what
what is dirty are you afraid of what
he's afraid of
well a couple chapters ago he was very
anti cat oh he doesn't like cats and he
does kind of he's kind of cat-like on
the rooftops
mmm so maybe Cat Man or kitty cat good
I'm Cat Man okay also it'll be
interesting if Mike managed to survive
this whole episode
I think it's possible since we're gonna
be running on tops of buildings yeah
place your bets now oh it was time I for
one think the cat man is a menace
oh I'm gonna stop the cat villains Oh
well that didn't last long but a good
vigilantes are wanted all right that's
that should be nothing we just got to
figure out how to get on top of these
yeah this really isn't that big a deal
is it no this is normal for a cat man
there's normally like boxes and stuff
yeah can you get out of that railing
it's just like a half foot higher but
then you can get up on that one I can't
fit oh wait oh now climb on our also I
might recommend eating some food cuz you
cannot make that no you need you need a
more I need to be able to run oh you
know where I think I know let me guess
disturbing the peace what's really
confusing is that we're providing peace
[Laughter]
gone insane back then the idea of a
comic book wasn't was nowhere close to
conceivable like what a superhero I
don't get no I'll get it it just sounds
like a lunatic so let me get this
straight Paul he dresses up put some
mask on his face and saves the people
he'll our police can't even do that
that guy robbed a bank
oh there's a reason why I killed him
I'll figure it out it's gotta go
the cops are below you you need to land
this parkour and I can't hurt cops right
be eating up their boots sick
this is it this is it perfect there's Oh
what are you doing here
you flinched oh here we go we can sit on
the planter box yeah oh here we go here
we go this is this is the moment leap of
faith all right every superhero does a
leap of faith oh boy just standing there
selling drugs how do you get up here oh
my god right now believe the city
doesn't deserve me all that could have
been avoided
I've seen enough superhero movies to
know that cops can't follow you if
you're on a roof it's a new city to us
we're still getting a lay of the land oh
you know what I know where I know where
I know how we can do this yeah oh yeah
where's the trouble how do you do a
dirty already slash bad it's kind of
hard
oh no oh dude on your neck you'd be dead
all right let's listen in on this would
you look at where's your favor oh I
gotta get back up yeah god they're gonna
give me
one of cat fans weaknesses is floor oh
no the Sun is rising
don't worry keeping the streets safe
that's it boys it's camping I'm faster
yes
Wow yes you know it's like you are legit
getting away actually kind of working
out Oh who's this guy that's an illegal
fire you need a permit for that bonfire
I gotta get back on buildings otherwise
there's no way these look like good
rooftops yeah yeah I think we can get on
them he's using the stairs oh come on
you can get there for sure yeah it is
there it is shoot that man
[Music]
[Laughter]
like a real superhero the bullets never
hit well I think we're cleaning up the
city I think it's going really well
there's the bank Oh probably back there
ya go
Oh perfect
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was like successful day successful
we made it on the rooftop survived a
little bit stopped some crime I think
now we should roam the streets and see
if we can find any like random
activities let's see if we can help them
[Laughter]
calm like a chump you jump
grandpa alright back to our patrol our
regular Patrol just just a simpleton
don't think nothing of me I'm not
worried I like you mask I'm actually it
speaking of which I need my raccoon hat
on just simple raccoon man definitely no
superhero here more an officer yeah you
let me know of any crimes this is the
nicest I've ever seen dirty arty well
that's cuz if I say anything bad they'll
tell the police yeah oh stop him yeah
we're tailing this guy we got a new lead
this guy is such a criminal I know you
can just tell
oh it's unless maybe you don't know who
I am I'm Cat Man
oh alright where's the other guy with a
shock no that's my blood cut myself
opening up a can of beans [ __ ] it's
marinara sauce oh the crowd just make me
back some snacks don't worry about me
just your average ordinary raccoon man
drunken disorderly Lerman Luhrmann's of
the alley
you keep run into the alley right there
and put your mask on and then and then
and then turn the corner put your mask
on and then and then kill oh this must
be like an upper tier henchman oh no one
saw that yeah you got a lot of blood on
that mask still no bounty though yeah
it's perfect
you're really really saving the city oh
you know where you should go to the
saloon to the right you should go check
in there and if there's anyone who's you
know acting up acting up then you run
into the back hallway put on your mask
but that kid so many potential criminals
quiet do quiet
this guy that guy this guy he looks up
to no good
get over here who you are for where are
you going
sorry wrong guy he's driving away I know
a crime that we can stop oh he talks a
lot of nonsense
no offense none taken nothing taken at
all hey stop these cans to the worst
we're on it camera I don't know I think
I took care of that I think so
[Music]
like stop objective is to avoid the
police it turns white with every person
it's like that scene in airplane where
it the air parcels going through the
airport he's like being confronted by
all these like Jehovah's Witnesses
beating up I've done nothing wrong
this also reminds me a scene from
Jumanji running in one direction good
thing I am a high on so much cocaine
[Laughter]
going there sick you're good knowing no
one at all so you meant to bring peace
to the city what have you become visibly
tense who are you Artie
[Laughter]
there's a part of the movie where I come
back stronger was a monologue so I think
I figured out the problem with the city
yeah
it's corrupt and you know you know where
that stems from what police station oh
we should kill everyone in the police
say that is exactly what I'm thinking
dynamite it's all I got
but that's probably good that's perfect
oh I'm still in a mission Wow well that
went very well
that went so well I think that went
pretty well I'm actually really
surprised we're still in a mission after
all that
I was just in my crypt so after some
investigation dirty ideas found out that
the entire San Denis Police Department
is corrupt yep that explains it right
because he's just trying to keep the
peace in there shooting at him this
makes so much sense it's a corrupt city
corrupt the only way you can deal with
this is the only way he knows how
killing we gotta go to the police
station you gotta go to the police
station you cleanse this city of
corruption I see you where's this
where's this corrupt police station
gonna make a quick pit stop first okay
[Music]
yeah just talk to her a little bit all
right
what are you looking at cowboy well I
ain't too sure I'm waiting for someone
interesting to turn oh she's probably
waiting for the cat man it was worth it
oh man she was probably that was
probably her arch nemesis that was and
took care of it just like that
we had to oh boy oh boy all right we're
gonna come back later
[Laughter]
Oh oh yeah yep yep I know you all know
that we're in here I think justice needs
to be served on this inmate yep oh yeah
get in your bed failed attempt and
Michael Hardy is dead is he for sure
that Vicki's dead can we can we check
could we go back we're gonna have to go
back cuz we need to we need to burn that
place the ground so that's fair we can
go we can go to the hotel [ __ ] well if
they'll let me there I shot that lady if
she's still there I'm gonna shoot her
again though yeah let's make this place
our home I'm miss Valentine
yeah perfect we're already elevated just
how we want it see you
perfect I nailed it stuck the landing
well for those of you who bet on Mike
surviving that's unfortunate all right
I'm gonna survey the building see
there's a way on top that's a tight
alley wow this is a this is good oh
there's a window oh yeah yeah okay okay
corrupt cops there one two three four
five five corrupt cops how am I gonna do
this maybe you could throw a knife out a
wall for a distraction cuz they clearly
don't see you up here yeah
oh you don't you know me you can't see
me
Oh God okay dynamite it is the cleanse
has begun you corrupt ass cops yeah yeah
yeah that'll do it that's good yeah this
is nice
I'll kill these guys in the cells well
they're coming in the side they tricked
you
Here I am oh my god you're so many
oh I can't can't go into Deadeye well I
think we cleansed we killed all the
corrupt ones we did the ones we left
alive there there okay that's right it's
the second generation of police now yeah
and we we've successfully cleaned up son
Denis we done good
all right well awesome that's chapter 12
before we go let's take a look at the
artis y'all have sent in show us your
artis hashtag I said that wrong hashtag
show us your artis all right let's take
a look at y'all's artis whoa
okay well we'll start off with this one
that's a cool looking face yeah I put
him in here I was like this is this is
who already wishes he was yeah we need
to get that skull I know and this is a
art underscore mega faucet on Twitter
but yeah I saw that one I was like that
one should be in there I think I think
this person had two as well but I said
with this one cuz that's badass I was
like that's pretty cool look two double
barrel shotguns we used to do that but
then I got lazy and stuff too creeping
both of them this is blue Nova Corgi I
like the yellow like moldy looking pants
that looks like one smelly ass already
right there yeah and look he's just got
like a dead animal on his head
and fishing guy once again sent us one
Oh seemed pretty good that's pretty good
those are dead skunk on the head like I
don't know what these are for us it's a
little squish I don't know if that's
what yeah I think it's the angle like
yeah take a picture of it that's uh
that's a nice looking already I love the
pistol and those are pretty awesome
slacks yeah they called we used to have
them ask those chaps oh this person
their name was I made this username just
for dirty arty so they could share these
pictures like alright well I'll put this
this end because they made it just to
share these pictures and definitely
it already we got going there nice horse
hopefully that horse doesn't die on you
that's that's awesome that's like the
best looking pirate I've seen as far as
the attire goes yeah second those pants
are perfect
this one we both saw we saw the look on
yeah that's a good one that's great by
John Williams seven thirteen yeah that
hat yeah we got him with the hat was
pretty funny he also like threw in a
little guy tied up and this gross ass
horse God that braided s tail that horse
looks so gross oh this one's grand this
is from Lee H 1989 so he actually posted
a video which I will show all Jonas of
him running from like 20 freakin wolves
is dead it's such a funny video seeing
them all like it looks like they were
eating like a dead carcass or something
and like they all see them and they
sprint tourism it's so many wolves like
I can't believe that's even possible in
this game well we all do we want to go
to bed we have the we have the dirty
arty show us your arty hashtag so some
of these didn't have us tagging them so
we missed them but I thought this one
was pretty good
the first one there it's kind of good
good setting to it
that's another skull we have to do
something with these skulls I know
and then that's another version that
they also had people I just want in the
horse Deborah the zebra looking yeah he
looks insane that's insane for sure
insanity saw that one oh I didn't know
that was that in the game I saw that and
I was like they're anacondas is that in
the different location I don't know
that's something we should look into or
maybe it's just like a easter egg maybe
you don't actually kill it it's just
hanging out oh my god yeah I was
surprised to see that we saw that one
that one kind of small but but solid
beard either the beards looking strong
oh oh yeah so this one hit man which I
wonder how they get the that's what we
needed we needed
the suit-and-tie and everything right
when we were doing the Hitman for sure
that's that's legit the dual wield there
them looks like he's roasting some
people proud of it looks very happy um
nice do they match plaid with they try
to match plaid with stripes never works
but dirty already knows no bounds a guy
who just quit his like cubical job yeah
looks like Dwight I mean there's more we
can keep going yeah whoa how long we've
seen that one at some point I like this
guy
beard or no at our at our favorite bar
hell yeah favorite bar and look at that
glove that's an awesome glove yeah it's
very contrast II but that's a lot of fur
I mean this is stuff we did last week
okay yeah definitely or any things we've
already done dude awesome yeah there's a
lot of them out there yeah you guys are
really sending them in and please
continue to do so those are all really
great well all right thank you guys
again for sending in your dirty Artie's
those are all fantastic please continue
to do so and Jake we have decided to
wrap up this first season of dirty arty
don't worry actors we're not done we're
not the next week there's a little treat
that Joey's been working on that we'll
have for next Friday right and then the
week after will go into season two
season two and we've got some exciting
plans some very requested plans to yes
definitely and if you guys have any
ideas for us please add them in the
comments on Twitter or on YouTube thank
you guys so much have a great rest of
your week that's see ya see ya
you